Welcome back, welcome back to video number
13. Now, up to this point, I'm just going
to give you a little reminder. Up to this
point in the leading indicators, we've
looked at businesses and consumers. And
just as a little reminder, I want you to
make sure that you're actually downloading
the files that are next to the,
the videos. You've really got to go
through those files and have a look at the
data and really try and learn in Excel how
to actually take the data from these
websites, go and visit the websites, go
through the same exercises, download the
data, put it in spreadsheets, build the
charts and map onto the charts, the S&P
500 and GDP growth, real GDP growth.
Once you start doing this, once you start
doing this, you really do start building a
nice picture and you get yourself a nice
skill set. You know, we go back to this
principle again, that we had in the
earlier parts of the video series, where
as a professional trader, what you really
should be doing is not really relying on
too much resources.
resources. You should be going out into
the world and taking that information
that's really important, that information
that's relevant and is going to
potentially make you money. And then
interpreting that information correctly
and drawing the correct conclusions and
then building your ideas and building your
portfolio and turning it into real hard
dollars.
Now, just make sure that as we're going
through the video series, you're actually
grabbing the downloads and going through
them. Now, we're going to move on to the
next leading indicator, which is the
Census Bureau's monthly report on building
permits.
And building permits come into the housing
sector and the housing data that we get
each month within the Housing Starts
report. And these numbers are very
important because the housing sector makes
up a very large percentage of US GDP. And
it's also been important, very much so in
recent years, because of the subprime
crisis. Now, a lot of people in the market
even professionals, even professionals,
and I get shocked by this a lot of the
time, even professionals misread and
misinterpret what building permits really
are. When we go to the presentation,
you're going to discover that building
permits don't just mean the amount of
permits in applications for building
residential houses. They actually have a
much wider significance. And professional
traders don't really see this significance
as much as other leading indicators
they think that building permits, they
think that building permits is somehow
less important. They don't really see the
bigger picture. Now, that actually creates
more opportunities. So it's actually a
very positive thing that people don't see
the bigger picture of building permits. So
let's go to the presentation.
of the Census Bureau of the Census
Bureau's monthly report on building
permits.
of the Census Bureau of the Census Bureau
of the Census Bureau. So we have multiple
indicators. We have multiple indicators.
Leading, coincident, lagging. But what do
we want to focus on? We want to focus on
predicting the future. So we want leading.
We want a leading indicator that's going
to tell us whether the US housing market
is going to explode in 12 months or
collapse in 12 months. And this one does
it with staggering accuracy.
of the US building permits. It's part of
the US housing starts report, which comes
out every month. And within the housing
starts report, you get three numbers. You
get housing starts itself. You get housing
completions. And you get building permits.
So let's try and
go through this logically. In terms of
economic indicators, housing starts is
that leading,
lagging or coincidence? Let's have a
guess. Who said coincidence? Housing
starts are coincidence.
What's a housing completion? Lagging and
building permits are leading. So housing
starts follow
building permits and housing completions
follow housing starts. What's the
definition of a
housing start? So this is residential
construction of houses in the United
States. Anybody know
what the definition is of a housing start?
Almost. The foundations have been set,
which
means the project has started. Housing
start. Not rocket science. I'm not from
NASA.
What's the definition of a housing
completion? Let's have a guess. The
structure has been built,
only cosmetic work required, and the house
has been listed for sale. What's a
building permit?
The housing developer goes to the local
state planning department and pays
anything between
$500 and $1,000 to apply for planning
permission to build the house. And they
get a building
permit. What follows? The housing start.
What follows? The housing completion.
So if there's lots and lots and lots and
lots of applications to build houses,
what's that
telling us? It's telling us that housing
developers are applying for more projects
and they're bullish.
Why would housing developers be bullish?
Because the building permits number is
actually one of the most
misunderstood numbers in the United
States, even by professional traders. What
else does this thing tell us?
It tells us and gives us an unbelievable
insight into the health of the US economy.
Why would a developer be bullish? Why
would a developer apply or increase their
applications for building permits?
Exactly. So let's go through supply and
demand.
What does a developer need from the bank
to actually go and build a residential
housing project?
A loan. They don't put money down 100% and
pay cash to build a residential
development.
They're going to borrow money from the
bank.
That's on the supply side. On the demand
side, they must expect a demand for them,
otherwise they wouldn't build them.
So what are they expecting?
They're expecting people to buy the houses
or that expectation's gone up.
Why? Because mortgages are now available.
The US consumer doesn't buy a house with
100% cash.
They buy them with 10% cash and 90%
borrowed money, a mortgage.
90% debt.
So what's the implication of the building
permits number?
It's a litmus test at any one point in
time as to the health and liquidity of the
US debt market.
In fact, when you're looking at the chart,
that's what you should be thinking.
But you should also be thinking, I'm
looking at the chart of the willingness of
banks to lend money.
That's what it looks like.
Building permits authorised.
Going back to 1959.
What you're looking at on the left-hand
side
is a seasonally adjusted, annualised rate
of building permit applications
at the aggregate level of all states in
the United States added up every month.
Why is it seasonally adjusted?
Because more projects come online in the
spring, so permits are applied for in the
winter.
So to smooth it out, they smooth out on a
seasonally adjusted, annualised rate.
What do we think of that chart?
Okay, let's start here.
Let's start in the early 90s.
Where we got this trend.
An ever-increasing trend.
Of building permit applications.
I remember this represents the liquidity
and health of the US debt market.
So we saw debt market growth.
And it was on a consistent basis, on a
consistent trend.
When it broke that trend, anybody know
what month that was?
June 06.
That's when it broke for the first time.
When it broke that trend.
When was the high of the US stock market?
That was FTSE.
October 07.
You were being told, 15 months before the
US market topped out,
that the economy, that housing market was
going to collapse.
Then what happens?
Well, we hit a trough here.
Anybody know what the month that trough
was?
Think of what happened with the ISM.
March 09.
They all bottomed at the same time.
What about here?
Why does that happen where they're on the
lowest rate in recorded history?
Housing developers.
They can't get financing.
People can't get mortgages.
And there's gazillions of foreclosures on
the market.
And they can't compete anyway.
When was this?
When did it break out of the previous high
here?
When did it go up through that level?
March 2012.
What was I doing in March 2012?
Buying the crap out of US house builders.
What did I do in April 2012?
Bought more.
What did I do in May 2012?
Go back one month.
April.
Put out a report on Market Watch.
James Fournier will remember this one.
Wrote a report for, do you know,
marketwatch.com in the States?
So I think the date was April 22nd or
April 23rd.
But I was already in the stocks.
I then wrote a report.
I said, you give it a title.
Give it a nice punchy title to get lots of
people to focus on it.
I cut and paste these charts in.
Explained exactly what I've just explained
to you.
That building permits are totally
misunderstood by the market.
And this is what it really means.
The US mortgage switch has just been
turned back on.
And a year from now, you're going to be
reading headlines in the paper, like,
property boom in Texas.
Et cetera, et cetera.
What's happening right now in the
newspapers?
And on television?
US housing market boom.
Could we be re-entering a US housing
market boom?
Well, we knew that a year ago.
Right?
How much did that trade pay?
180%.
It made 55% of my money last year, which
was just under $600,000.
Thank you very much.
Easiest trade of the year.
So if you just interpret the...
No inside information, by the way.
The fairy godmother didn't come and tell
me.
Dead easy.
And the trade was actually long US house
builders, short Chinese property stocks,
in Hong Kong.
Why do you think I put that trade on?
We're going to talk about tomorrow how you
structure trades differently.
But why do you think specifically the
trade was structured in that way?
Any ideas?
So long US property stocks, short Chinese
property stocks.
How do you think you're going to take
yourself from the business shop?
Yep.
So hedging out market risk.
So trying to take the least amount of risk
possible for the highest amount of return.
But why was it structured in that way?
Firstly, well, the whole idea was it was a
cycle switch play.
As in Chinese property stocks are at the
height of their bull market, the height of
their business cycle.
And US property stocks are at the bottom.
So you go long, short.
And the Hong Kong dollar is pegged to the
US dollar.
Which means there's no currency risk.
So you've got a nice layup trade where you
can start off.
It started off the position.
So I bought three US property stocks and
shorted three Hong Kong property stocks.
And they were all 1% each in the
portfolio.
So they totaled 6%.
So it was like having six options in your
portfolio.
And it made 15% in a month.
Which signals to me one thing.
I'm right, so I should get bigger.
So I doubled the size of the position to
12% in the portfolio in April.
And wrote on Market Watch what everybody
should be focusing on.
In a year's time, there'll be a US housing
boom.
Then in May, it returned another 15%.
So I doubled the position again.
It ended up becoming 25% of the portfolio.
And then it went on a tear.
And made another 140% over five months.
Not bad.
And then, one week, it just goes a bit
wrong.
Goes against me.
And I get stopped at.
Whatever.
I'm up 180%.
But that was March last year.
And on the watch list.
So as traders, you have watch lists.
And we look at this tomorrow.
When we look at price action indicators.
And technical indicators.
You have all of these situations on your
watch list.
That was on my watch list from October
2011.
So it was on the watch list for a good
four or five months.
Before I was like, okay, I'm going to pull
the trigger now.
Because this is about to happen.
When you see this happening.
And then it goes up.
What happened to that article when it went
up on Market Watch.
Within 48 hours, there were 128 comments
on the article from people in the United
States.
48 hours later, I went through all the
comments.
And just marked them in a spreadsheet as
positive, negative, or neutral.
As in, are they dissing me about the
article?
Or are they negative on the US housing
sector?
If either one of those is true about the
comment, it goes in negative.
If it's neither here nor there, the
comment doesn't mean anything, it becomes
neutral.
If they say the article is really, really
good and insightful, and they're positive
about it.
Or they agree with what I'm saying, it's a
positive.
What percentage were negative out of the
comments within 48 hours?
95%.
So then you go through all the short
interest data of all the stocks, and you
realize that
every retail trader in the market is short
US housing stocks.
So double the size of the position again.
And then sent out the spreadsheet on email
to 10,000 people.
And said, everybody's short US housing
stocks.
Smart traders are buying them.
They're going to squeeze like crazy.
And this could be 100% no problem.
Once you put that out, it takes one hedge
fund manager to agree.
And it's over.
Everyone gets squeezed out.
And that's what happened.
That's what it looks like versus GDP
growth.
So you can see it just follows all the
time.
Housing starts follow permits.
Completions follow housing starts.
There they are, all on one chart.
That's zoomed into last year.
So that's the breakout level.
So in March when the report came out, it's
the February report in March.
Yeah.
And then boom, it just went through that
level.
So if you watch these things closely and
you're on top of them, if you're on top of
your leading
indicators, you'll generate no end of
trading ideas and opportunities.
And it's all publicly available.
No fairy godmother.
So it doesn't just tell us the potential
GDP growth.
It tells us the health of the liquidity in
the U.S. debt market.
That's really important.
You're looking at the ability or the
willingness of banks and financial
institutions to lend to
housing developers and consumers in the
United States.
That's what you're looking at.
And you can use it to connect the dots
across all sorts of sectors.
So home builders, banks, furniture stocks,
timber stocks, steel, chemicals, paints,
anything that's
related to the U.S. housing sector.
These are the laggards that you'll see
every month.
So when you look at them, it either
confirms or denies what you were thinking
in building
permits months before.
Pending home sales, that's just the next
step after completions.
New home sales, that's when somebody
actually buys it, buys the new home.
Existing home sales are second-hand homes
that are being bought and sold.
The Case-Shiller index, which is
essentially a tweak of the housing market
index, as in the
value of U.S. houses on aggregate.
So like the average value of a house in a
state, the average value of a house in the
United States
across the board.
All those follow the leading indicator,
which is building permits.
So they either confirm or deny that you're
correct.
Not difficult.
Why is it important?
Obvious, predicting GDP.
Predicting stock market returns.
Use it as a head check in tandem with
business and consumer surveys.
And it gives us default trade ideas in
sectors related to home building.
You'll get the spreadsheets.
Everything's going to be fine.
Okay, welcome back.
Let's go through a summary of why building
permits are so important.
I mentioned at the beginning of this video
that a lot of professional traders, even
good
professional traders, misinterpret what
building permits really are.
And this actually creates a lot of
opportunities.
And this is why building permits is one of
my personal favourite leading indicators.
Because it's quite widely misunderstood
what it means.
Building permits, as you saw in the
presentation, is not just the permits that
are granted
in terms of planning and building U.S.
residential housing projects.
What they also are is a representation of
the health and liquidity of the U.S.
banking system.
Because when you think about how this
industry works, we have a supply and
demand side.
And the supply is from home builders and
the demand is from U.S. consumers.
The suppliers, the home builders, are
taking loans from U.S. banks in order to
finance the housing projects.
And on the demand side, the U.S. consumers
are taking loans, mortgages, to finance
the purchase of residential housing.
So what you've actually got here is a
second derivative leading indicator, which
tells you how the debt-driven economy of
the United States, how healthy and how
liquid the banking system is.
And that's really important because, for
example, last year, 2012, and actually
over the last four or five years, this has
been really important due to the subprime
crisis.
So what we saw was a collapse in the U.S.
banking system.
And if you look at the charts and you look
at the data for building permits, you'll
see that this happened one to two years
before the banks collapsed.
You saw building permits fall from a
long-term trend from the early 90s.
And then what you saw in the last four
years was building permits at all-time
lows.
And then February, March 2012, building
permits as a representation of the U.S.
banking sector broke out to the upside.
And that was extremely bullish because for
the first time in four or five years,
building permits were predicting health
improvement and liquidity improvement in
the U.S. banking system.
And therefore, predicting higher earnings
for home builders and higher GDP levels in
the United States.
So building permits is not just about the
housing sector and the amount of building
permits that are granted to home builders
at a state level.
It's also about the health and liquidity
of the U.S. banking system.
And it gives us very, very good clues as
to the future prospects of the U.S.
economy and whether we should be buying
the stock market or shorting it now.
So up to this point, we've got U.S.
businesses, U.S. consumers, and we've got
the housing market and the health of the
banking system.
These are fantastic leading indicators and
a great suite of indicators for you to
decide whether you're going to go long,
short, or be market neutral in the United
States.
Now, there are other indicators out there,
and there are other leading indicators,
and I'd encourage you to use them.
You know, I've said throughout the video
series that if you do have other stuff
that you want to include in the total wish
framework, then feel free to do so.
But make sure you put the macro in the
idea generation, the micro in the idea
generation, make sure that technical
analysis and price action indicators are
in the section of gatekeeping, risk
management is in the having discipline
section in the risk management area, and
self-awareness indicators in the
self-awareness area.
Because don't kid yourself, your ideas
come from certain areas, your gatekeeping
has to come from price action and timing
indicators, your self-awareness comes from
trades that you've already done, and your
risk management comes on your real
portfolio.
And this framework is what professional
traders use.
Now, there are other macro indicators that
we're going to look at, but they are macro
indicators that lag the economy, and also
tell us what's happening now in the
economy.
You'll see all the time in the mainstream
media, indicators reported on television,
in newspapers, online, and of course these
people are going to tell you that these
indicators are really important,
because they want you to watch their TV
program, they want you to buy their
newspaper, and they want you to hit their
website.
That's the business they're in, so they're
not going to tell you, here's an
indicator, it's not really that important,
don't bother reading about it, or don't
bother watching.
Of course they're going to tell you it's
important, but this is just the noise.
This is the noise in the market that you
have to cut out, because these indicators
are coincident and lagging, and they don't
help us as traders.
What they do is provide liquidity for us
to get at, because we're trying to predict
the future using leading indicators, and
using the stock market, commodities,
currencies, and rates as a proxy, and
taking positions now.
So, we're going to look at, in the next
video, some confirmation indicators.
What do I mean by confirmation, well, if
coincident indicators are coming out here,
and you've made your decision 6, 12 months
previously, and lagging indicators are
coming out here, 12 months later.
The coincidence of the lagging indicators
are either going to confirm or deny what
you were thinking 6 months before.
So, let's move on to the next video,
confirmation indicators, and I'll see you
in the intro for that video.